Russia, represented by official business circles and the
public, is sincerely interested in
further deepening multifaceted
trade, investment and humanitarian
ties with the continent, which meets the
needs of all our states.
We understand the importance of an
uninterrupted supply of
food to African countries; this is important for
socio-economic development and for
maintaining political stability.
Therefore, always  We are paying and will pay
special attention to the supply of
wheat, barley, corn and other
grain crops to our African friends, including as
humanitarian aid. A
paradoxical picture is emerging. On the
one hand, Western countries are creating
obstacles to the supply of our grain and
fertilizers, and on the other hand, I will say, they are directly
hypocritically blaming us for the current
crisis.  situation on the global
food market,
our country is able to replace
Ukrainian grain both commercially and
in the form of gratuitous assistance to the most
needy countries in Africa.
Moreover, this year we are again
expecting a record harvest; we will be
ready in the coming months in the
next 3-4 months  We will provide free of charge to
Burkina Fasu
Zimbali Somalia
Central African Republic
25-50 thousand tons of grain and we will provide
free delivery of these products
to consumers
Unfortunately, at the moment it is impossible to return
to this deal because it does
not fulfill it,
de facto de facto it was never
executed therefore  This is not impossible,
however, President Putin has made
it clear that Russia is ready to
immediately resume the deal as soon as
it is completed